they're doing this people be tough right
and then people began actually came out
it didn't do that well I'm out already I
think so Al Gore could be the world's
first carbon billionaire former vice
president become the world's first
carbon billionaire after investing
heavily in green energy no that's okay
that part's okey riot because if he's
investing in these companies and the
companies start making money which like
already so sure solar employs more
people now than coal does yes amazing
well I'm coal but that was one of the
dumbest things when when Trump became
president I gotta bring back call like
what how about bring back knocking rocks
together start fires it's as if the
typewriter companies got together it
made sure you never bought a computer
like we're going to computers illegal
because anymore it's like you know yes
but listen I got it one thing that you
always gotta acknowledge is that like
this you know when you change
infrastructures people are gonna get
hurt yeah you know I mean like I mean
for those coal miners man that's what
they've done their whole life it's been
an honorable [ __ ] thing and they've
you know so you can't just sort of be
like hey we're switching infrastructure
see yeah you know there's got to be some
deep understanding of conjugative
consequences and helping people who are
gonna be yeah you know put you know
train them how to put up so you know
solar panel about universal basic income
of your look oh yeah yeah no no I've
thought about that a lot you know it's a
big thought when right consideration
when it comes to automation technology
and you know with the automation thing
it's so true right because you know when
you think about what's been going on
with the last election you know and
everybody was like oh you know like you
know what's happening with blue-collar
people workers and beam which is totally
true but like man it's not China
it's automation right and that's what's
a what really is gonna screw up the
whole nature of work you know for
everybody from truck drivers you know
even to me the University Professors is
we got this the AI you know the
automation coming on and right what do
you do what do you do when a university
professor is one day gonna be retro that
that kids are gonna want to learn online
they're gonna want to learn through some
sort of an interactive course so that
you can get on your phone rather than go
to an actual physical place it's
possible you know I mean it's possible
but I think and this is gonna be the
whole question with the new economy
all right whatever whatever happens
whatever we're moving into is finding
those places where you know what I don't
want a machine right I mean so right now
like so when the what is it the MOOCs
came out the massively online courses
yeah that was like five years ago when
Syme touch it universities are done
everybody's gonna take these online
courses it never happened you know
because people want to be together they
want to learn they want the experience
of a happy you know my part of my
students is not just lecturing though
I'm agree literature my students are
probably I bet you are man you're good
talker I had one student say I know the
reviews you get at the end the guy said
hey I hate to say this but you know you
should make those tapes for people to go
to sleep because every class that's your
voice boom it's like you have a nice
voice you know that's yeah so whoever is
I think that I think people will always
with education there'll be some
component of it that yeah sure you can
learn it online one too but I think like
you know we're gonna have to they'll
they'll be put there be a place for like
people coming in and like learning in
groups and having somebody who'd like
their whole life studying the thing
telling you you know what's going right
like there's a lot of things we're like
and we've lost lot of this um mentorship
or apprenticeship mmm-hmm right there's
a lot of things you needed somebody who
know you know we spent their whole life
going oh you know you crank it this way
not that way because you got it that way
you'll never work you know right you
can't learn that from watching a video
or something yeah well there's certain
things martial arts which is a big part
of my life you have to learn from a
person you gotta have tiny things that
they must show you while you're doing it
but you can learn a lot of things from
videos no no doubt yeah there's a lot of
things that people are putting up online
instructional courses and stuff and I
use some of them you know if I have to
fix my sink all for sure it's kind of
amazing yeah I know yeah so you know I
think like with everything so let's
circle back to the ubi um you know like
with everything we're gonna have to
invent new ways we will because we're
just human beings like there's a way in
which we're gonna find you know niche
places that there will be economies
where people make things but yeah in the
end I mean ubi may be necessary yeah I
think it may really be necessary because
if there's no work you know I mean
that's a recipe for disaster
no for your Democratic Society yeah I
just hope we can move past this idea
that everybody who needs that as some
sort of a welfare brat yeah right right
well you know once there's no work at
all
you know I mean they're good because
like you know this is the the thing that
I would like with uh self-driving cars
right so I asked this question a lot and
I've written about this sort of like
okay everyone like we gotta have
self-driving cars we're heading toward
self-driving cars like self-driving cars
will destroy the last good blue-collar
job in America you know truck driving
right you know really good livelihood
for a lot of people and it's like our
words can eliminate it it's like why
like do we have to like okay yeah
there's you telling me there's gonna
safety safe that's what they say right
but in Brown it's not entirely clear
right you know that that that will work
and you know what is the cut for the for
the lives that are lost in the driving I
mean you know the car crashes is that
gonna be worth the social upheaval that
comes from not having any work anymore
so I mean just like they're these huge
yes bearing down on them yes if it's
your friend or your mom loved ones or
yeah but these calculus I mean you know
if it tears down if the if wiping out
these jobs destroys democracy right and
you end up with you know if that's a
silly though that doesn't seem possible
I just think that what it's gonna do is
gonna make travel safer and then we have
to figure out well these jobs that
people got right from traveling how do
we replace that that income yeah right
well one of the things is we're gonna
we're gonna have to start teaching kids
to be creative yeah well you niche that
I think there's gonna be places where
like the now you'll have so listen I'm
not arguing that we shouldn't have no I
know you're not you're just being you're
just looking at all the variables
yeah and I'm asking like the cop you
know we're moving so rapidly into this
new world right that like who's deciding
for us who's deciding that we want car
yeah well you know we're told that we're
gonna get it but like a lot of these
things I think they're you know there
needs to be a little bit more dialogue
democracy rights and having this stuff
shoved down our throats and totally you
know I mean